موعد جديد لكن يبدو انه قابل للتاجيل فهو
مشروط بحل خلاف يبدو معقدا بعض الشيء
الاتفاق السياسي الذي كان من المقرر
توقيعه اليوم السبت اجيل الى السادس من
ابريل على ان تحل نقاط الخلاف خلال الايام
المقبله الاجتماع الذي انعقد في القصر
الرئاسي وضم رئيس مجلس السياده ونائبه
والقوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
للخروج بهذا الحل لم يستغرق وقتا لكنه ترك
قضايا معقده تتطلب الكثير من الزمن الا
اطراف الحاضره بالاكبار العسكريه
ان تكثف من جهدها لحل هذه القضايا الفنيه
العالقه خلال الفتره من الليله وحتى يوم
السادس من ابريل
الورشه المعنيه بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري
اختتمت قبل ايام دون توصيات او نقاط اتفاق
بل انها وسعت الخلافه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الذين تحدثا بشفافيه
غير معهوده عن كل ما يراه احدهما في الاخر
اما الموضوع الذي ادى الى تاجيل للاتفاق
والمتمثل بوضع جداول زمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع داخل الجيش فالامر ما زال
معقدا بتقدير الخمسه ايام غير كافيه لانه
البون شاسع جدا ما بين مطالب الدعم السريع
ومطالب القوات المسلحه والامر قد ياخذ زمن
اطول انا اعتقد اسبوعين قد تكون كافيه
الشارع السوداني يبدو قلقا من التوترات
القائمه بين الجيش والدعم السريع ومن تاخر
تشكيله حكوميه المدنيه تهتم ولو قليلا
بحالهم الطريقه المشي في هذه انا ما شايف
افق غريبه للحل لانه كل يعني اتضح انه
السلطه الناس البلد ولا بالبعاش ولا
بالاكل ولا بالشرب ولا بشيء الموضوع ماشي
ده يعني بين الدعم السريع والجيش اول شيء
يفيدنا يعني دايرين الناس يعني باي حاجه
دار يوقف عن احداث بين الدعم السريع
والجيش واصلا لو حصل بلدي ما في خير ثاني
دي مشكله سياسيه ما مشكله شعبيه وموطنيه
نحن في الوقت الحالي محتاجين لحكومه تدير
لنا الامور نعرف حلينا ولا علينا
قد نشهد في السادس من ابريل احتفال
السياسيا يضم الاطراف المختلفه بعد حل
قضاياهم العالقه وقد نشهد تكرارا لمشهد
اليوم بتاجيل جديد في موعد الاتفاق نهائي
لنيع يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم